That concludes the public speakers list.
And now we will move on to welcome
the Director, margaret Wallace Brown and Roger Hamilton,
to provide the Planning and Development Budget workshop presentation.
Welcome, Director, and the floor is yours. Thank you. Good afternoon,
council members. Let me begin by introducing
the team that I have with me today. We may be relying on them for
some answers to questions, so I want to make sure I introduce them.
First of all, at my right is Roger Hamilton. He is our department CFO
and he leads the finance team, which includes Alejandro Garcia,
Maribel Torres and Donnella Gamilian. Also with us
today is our communication team and council liaison, elise Marion
and Anna Sedillo. And then the other part of our
leadership in our department is our Deputy Director,
Jennifer Austland, and our Assistant Director in Chief Transportation
Planner, David Fields. And so I may be leaning on some of them for
some of your questions. Let me go ahead and start.
So my name is Margaret Wallace Brown. I'm the director of the Planning and Development
Department. And before I present an overview of the
Planning and Development Department budget, I'd like to take a moment to reaffirm
my deep appreciation for your support of the planning team and all the
work we do. We take great pride in being a resource
for the Mayor and Council districts and our fellow departments.
We take our work very seriously when we work with you. In 2021,
we adopted a new mission statement growing and Preserving
Houston's Diverse Communities to create a resilient city with
record number of platts and permits and an increasing portfolio of
new projects. 2021 has been our most productive year and
our most innovative year. I'd like to demonstrate how we are fulfilling
that mission as I share a few highlight reels of our accomplishments.
First of all, our platting requests hit an all time high with
over more than 3000 platts in 2021. That was a 25%
increase on our previous record year, which was 2020.
We also saw a steady increase in building permits, with 22
300 building permits planners reviewing approximately 1200
plans per month. On a different
note, Friedmanstown was designated as the city's first heritage district.
We also added ten more landmarks, a new historic district,
and we have another one in the works. Our team is engaging with residents in
Glenburg Valley, where we conducted a window workshop and worked on design
guidelines for three historic districts.
More accomplishments include our transportation planning area,
which our Vision Zero Action plan earned a
Gold Award for implementation from the Texas Chapter of the American Planning
Association. Vision Zero is implementing all 13
priority actions, and highlights include continuing engagement
to identify locations of concern updating the city street designs,
redesigning ten high injury network locations, and receiving
$4 million in highway safety improvement funding from Techstot.
The first more space Main Street patio opened with Little
Dipper. Followed shortly after that with Shay McElroy, the Flying
Saucer and Finn Hall. The More space Main Street initiative
was a great success and was approved for an extension,
keeping it going through 2023 in 2021,
together with our partners, we completed the Austin Hutchins,
Gray, Leland and Polk Street Bikeways,
including Cullen Boulevard. Also, they were initiated
in response to the Build 50 challenge. We added the Clear Lake West
Chase Trail extensions and segments of the Spring Branch Trail.
So now we have High comfort bikeway off of East Freeway
at Federal and Maxi and these complete 40 miles
of high comfort bike network in our city.
The transportation team also engaged with the community to build safety improvements
in Briar Meadows and set a guest with council
members Thomas and Jackson. We partnered with Harris
County Health Department, received funding from MD Anderson to start the
city's first Safe Routes to School program in
Acres Home. Our Livable Places Action Committee celebrated
its first anniversary, reached consensus on recommendations from Chapter
42 technical amendments, which you graciously approved yesterday,
established a focus group to work on conservation districts, and released
a single family residential survey that garnered over 1200
responses. We received a grant from the AARP,
which we used to organize an accessory dwelling unit
garage apartment for many design competition to promote
compact, affordable housing design options for Houstonians.
The grant funded a series of workshops and the design contest and
culminated in the publication of a book, all of which was managed,
implemented and designed by our staff in the complete communities
planning and development led initiatives such as Neighborhood Character preservation Tool
Workshops, Lights on Houston Community Events Building
Food Security Workshop and working with CenterPoint Energy Agency's
Action Program. So these are our accomplishments over
the past year, but I also want to provide a very brief overview of our
priorities, new projects and frequently recurring quests that we're expecting to
come for the coming year. As all of you know, we're working with council districts
on Redistricting, both on the ongoing public engagement as well as
the technical and data analysis support for realignment of district
boundaries. That process will continue through September of 2022.
Staff is creating a team to provide demographic and population
projections for the city of Houston. Up until now, we've not projected
population, we've simply identified what other agencies
have calculated. So projections will be new for us and
for the city, and it will support other city departments in right sizing their
service operations. Our transportation planners have so
many projects, it's hard to keep up, but I hope you had a chance
to listen to the Mayor's State of Mobility address this afternoon. A transcript and a
video is going to be available later today, but in addition to that,
we have increased coordination with Metro,
specifically about the University Corridor and the Intercatty Bus Rapid
Transit lines. We're also receiving frequent requests for
connectivity studies in various council districts and
Houston is the largest city in the United States without a map designating
truck routes, which means that freight travel often cuts through residential neighborhoods.
So in the coming year, the citywide Freight Map project
will coordinate with council members and neighborhoods to secure some relief for
them. And when it comes to increasing Houstonian's
equity, we're still collaborating with the Kinder Institute on the Equity
Indicators project to provide transparency, accountability and
to refine operations for all city departments to increase
equity across our city. The initial analysis is nearly completed but
and the program will require ongoing management and measure to measure
success in closing the gaps.
Our ongoing work with neighborhood resiliency plans address storm recovery,
watershed boundaries and other challenges like climate adaption, risk reduction,
economic development, infrastructure modernization and social empowerment.
Currently there are three plans to be completed by 2023, with another
three to be completed afterward. And staff is developing a
replicable framework for other neighborhoods to follow in creating their own
resiliency plans. And our minimum lot size and
minimum building line programs, which are so popular for neighborhoods, are reaching
their 20 year threshold, which means
that we're creating significant increase in we're getting requests for
significant increase in renewals on top of the average projected new
applications. And finally,
historic preservation team we've created.
Two new historic districts have been petitioned and we
are working with the Economic Development Office for review and administration
of the historic Site tax exemption program, which is growing in popularity.
We expect conservation districts to presented to city Council within
the next few months. A conservation district for Independence Heights will
probably follow shortly thereafter. We see conservation districts
as providing neighborhoods another tool for protecting their character.
So I'm excited about all the partnerships we've forged and look forward
to working with you on another collaborative year.
Let's dig into the numbers now. The Planning and
Development Department operates out of four separate funds. It's important
to note, and I will discuss this in detail later, that while expenditures
are specific to a fund's function, our team
members operate in a silo free environment. In the
Planning Department, it's talent, not titles, that informs the
work of a team member does. And very few of our team members conduct one
job within one fund. Most handle projects in multiple
funds and we assign the costs accordingly.
I'm telling you this because we stress importance of
knowledge beyond their cubicle. It's my belief that this provides
better professional training to our team and makes for a better city employee.
The result is that we utilize a series of inner fund chargebacks and
reimbursements that will seem confusing at first, but I'll explain them
in detail as we get to them. So the first fund is the city's
general fund. The FY 23 budget is $3,000,925
$3,925,384
with 23.1 full time equivalents.
The fund supports our community engagement and transportation planning efforts
as well as our management and customer support services.
The second fund, the Department's Special Revenue Fund, supports the
work of the majority of our team members. This fund receives
fees from and pays for services related to
land development activities within the 671 sq.
Mi of the City of Houston, as well as the 1600 additional
square miles in the city's extraterritorial jurisdiction.
The team at the permitting center are also on this fund. The third
fund, the city's central services revolving fund also known
as the Enterprise GIS or just simply Egis fund,
supports the work of our GIS team located both at 611
Walker and at the Houston Emergency center as a central service revolving
fund operation. All expenditures in this area are charged
back to the department that consume our services under their restricted accounts.
The FY 23 budget is $1,736,847
with 11.5 full time employees.
And finally, the Historic Preservation Fund, which is a small fund used
for nonpersonal special preservation activities that
was created several years ago with the proceeds of the sale of some city owned
historic fire stations. I'd like to take the time to discuss
the programming and the core functions we handle in the Planning Department. Our department
consists of seven divisions community and Regional Planning,
transportation Planning, GIS Services,
historic Preservation, Development Services,
Management Services and the Director's Office for
Community and Regional Planning. This group is led by Deputy Director Jennifer Austland
and directly supports community planning with programs such as Complete Communities
minimum Lot Size Building Line prohibited yard parking.
They are also responsible for broader regional planning, such as annexations
and changes to boundaries, including the city's extraterritorial jurisdiction.
This group is the group currently working with you on Council Redistricting.
The next division is Transportation planning. Led by David Fields, the city's Chief
Transportation Planner, the division leads the city's
systems level strategic Mobility planning. This function includes management
of the city's Complete Streets and Transportation Plan, Vision Zero,
the Major Thoroughfare and Freeway plan, the Houston Bike Plan,
rail related planning, local area studies and
external transportation funding and grant efforts.
This is the team that's facilitating the discussions about the North Houston Highway
Improvement Project, and some of our newest initiatives include
connectivity studies for Houston neighborhoods the GIS
Services Division. Led by Assistant Director Larry Nerth,
this division manages and maintains much of the city's GIS information,
provides and coordinates regional emergency providers with mapping and
analysis for effective emergency services. As I often say,
if you need an ambulance and it can find you, that's because our GIS
group told it how to get there. This is also the group that provides the
map indicating services, facilities and developments within your district.
The next division is historic preservation. Roman McAllen is
the city's Historic Preservation Officer and he leads this group.
They facilitate the process of identifying and maintaining the city's historic
resources through engagement with neighborhoods and property owners.
This group manages certificates of appropriateness applications pertaining
to Chapter 33 of the Code of Ordinances, as well as coordinating state
and federal review of historic resources development
services. Deputy Director Jennifer Austin leads this division
also which oversees many development related activities including
subdivision and development, platting and site plan review at the Houston
Permitting Center. The last two are management
Services and support the division responsible for operational support
of the department, including budgeting, purchasing commission support,
customer service and public information and open records.
And then finally, the Director's Office, which handles all internal communications
such as employee onboarding and training, as well as communications
with the Mayor's office in your council, district offices and the public.
Moving on to Revenues by Funds this
slide is an overview of the proposed FY 23 revenue by fund in comparison
to the department's estimated FY 22 revenue. Overall,
we are proposing a revenue increase of 139,000
across all funds focusing on the General Fund line.
Revenue into the general fund is primarily from a chargeback from the
department's special revenue fund. As I mentioned earlier,
team members who are primarily paid out of the General Fund
but spend some portion of their time working on development related activities
that support the Special Revenue Fund. Their activities are
reimbursed to the General Fund. The General Fund revenue is projected
to increase by 77,000 or 5.5%
from the FY 22 estimate. Moving on
to the special revenue fund. This is Planning and Development special revenue
fund dedicated to the department's development
related services. These are services as a
regulator to ensure orderly development in the city and our
extraterritorial jurisdiction. They include functions such
as the review of Platts, residential site plans and development plats,
including work with the Planning Commission as well as our site plan review at the
Houston Permitting Center. The Special Revenue Fund is funded with revenue
from fees associated with these reviews and dedicates that revenue for services in
support of development activity. A portion of that revenue
is received by the Special Revenue Fund is due to team members who
are primarily paid out of Special Revenue Fund but spend some portion of their
time working on community engagement, transportation, planning efforts and management
customer support activities that are technically General Fund.
We expect a slight decrease in the revenue of 43,000 or
4% 4%
of this fund compared to FY 22 for fluctuations
in revenue from various other sources. The next line shows
Central Services revolving fund, also known as the Enterprise GIS.
The fund provides critical mapping services to the city,
including creation and maintenance of the city's underlying mapping data.
The fund receives revenue from departments across the city to pay
for GIS related services. The revenue to this fund is
based on actual expenditures and as a result the revenue can go
up or down depending on vacancies in the fund or other cost saving measures.
This fund is expected to see a revenue increase of 107,000
or 6.6% and the final fund is
the Historic Preservation Fund. It was created by ordinance and is
funded through the proceeds from the sale of historic fire stations.
The purpose of this fund is to promote preservation and enhancement of the
city's historic resources.
The revenue to It is simply interest on the Fund balance and we're anticipating
a 17% decrease in revenues this year.
Overall, department revenues increase 139,000
for all funds.
Shifting to Expenditures this slide is an overview of the
FY 2023 budgeted budget
in comparison to the FY 22 projected current budget.
Overall, we're proposing an expenditure decrease of approximately 1,546,000
across all funds. Is that correct? The slide
provides a quick overview of expenditures. General Fund
we're proposing an increase of 14,000, or 0.4%.
The increase is largely due to hope.
To the Hope increase, Special Revenue Fund is proposed to have
a decrease of 1,629,000
or 12.1% resulting in a
decrease from Indirect Cost and Consulting Services and
Central Services Revolving Fund proposing an increase of 69,000
or 4.1% resulting from Hope and increases in
interfund charges. Finally, the Historic Preservation Fund has no
change.
This is the General Fund breakdown of
expenditures. Personnel versus non
personnel approximately 3.9 million in expenditures
which includes 77% for personnel costs
and 23% for non personnel cost in
the non personal expenditures. The 887,000
non personnel expenditure cost for the General Fund is broken
down. The largest category is the restricted
accounts. These expenses are not controlled by the Department and make up
97% of the non personnel cost of this fund and
then services and supplies about 33,000 or 3%
of the non personnel expenditures.
Next slide. This slide illustrates the projected
budget expenditures for the Special Revenue Fund. The Fund's approximate
11 million in expenditures includes 57% for
personnel costs and 43% for non personnel cost
in FY 23. The nonpersonal cost for the Department's Special Revenue
Fund is as follows indirect cost recovery is 8%
or 411,000. This cost is for
indirect services provided by Central services departments and is not
controlled by the Department. Interfund Services 29%
is the chargeback that's paid to General Fund for development related
activities that I mentioned earlier. Plat Tracker and
Historic Tracker web Application Redesign I want to point out
that this is a major expense this fund will see for the next several years.
Plat Tracker, which is the primary portal through which all
development related applications are submitted, is close to ten years
old and is built on 13 year old technology.
We've been working closely with It and Special Purchase and Strategic
Purchasing for two years to develop an RFP for the reconstruction of
this portal later this summer in June,
you'll see a contract on your agenda to actually begin rebuilding
this application. The restricted accounts
is 17% of the non personnel cost and is not controlled by the Department and
supplies and services is a combined 8% for
supplies and services, computer supplies and so forth. Next slide
the breakdown of the FY 23 expenditures for Central
Services revolving fund. The fund's approximately
1.7 million in expenditures includes 86%
for personnel cost and 14% for non personnel costs
in FY 23. The non personnel costs for the fund are broken down.
49% includes various services and charges related to
the fund, including technology, services and software.
And then 40% of the non personnel cost in this fund is not controlled
by the Department. Those are restricted accounts. And finally,
11% is for computer supplies, offices, et cetera.
Next slide. The breakdown of the proposed FY 23 expenditures
for the Historic Preservation Fund include approximately 150,000
in expenditures and is entirely for non personnel cost. There are
no FTEs paid for out of this fund. The nonpersonal
cost includes miscellaneous support services, which include
funding for translation services for the Historic Commission meetings and the completion
of the design guidelines for the historic areas in Houston.
This slide shows our FY 23 projected fund balance
I'm sorry projected General Fund budget expenditures net change
to our FY 2022 projected current budget.
The FY 23 projected current budget is 3.9 million.
There's a one time operating budget adjustment for the position that was funded in
FY 22 for the Office of Resilience and Sustainability that our
Ara will now fund contractual or mandated adjustments
of 115,000 that consist of the municipal pension reduction
and an increase in the restricted accounts and hope pay increases
resulting in an operating program increase of 15,000.
This brings our FY 2023 projected budget to
3.9 million or an increase of 0.4%.
Any questions? Thank you for your presentation,
council Member Alcorn. Thank you
Chair. And thank you, Director, for all the great work you do at the Planning
Department. Thanks for talking about Plat tracker. I was going to
ask about the increase in management.
I guess it's under the management consulting services. That's the
big thing. And I know we we budgeted last year $2.6 million
in that line item and spent $300,000. Can you just talk
to me about that? Was it just delayed or
were we expecting to spend that last year or what have you? We did expect
to spend it last year, so about two years ago we started working with it
on looking at how can we fix what we have because it is old,
so let's just fix it. And it's answer was
we really can't fix it. We need to really start from scratch. And so we
expected it to be a shorter time frame in order to do the RFP and
to get the money spent for rebuilding it. It actually took longer
because we were more detailed. We went through a
very robust conversation with
the bidders on this and have developed an incredibly secure
program that it supports that we're going to move forward
with. The 300,000 that was spent last year was actually what
led us to such a good resolution in that we had a contract
with Gartner and Company to help us actually draft the RFP
got it. And since they didn't bid on it and so that's like
a lesser expense, the $1.9 million in the 2.6,
do we expect there to be more in coming years towards this you said this
will be a major expense for it'll be an expense for
at least seven years. It is a one year implementation project with six
years of full, virtually 24 hours support
for our customers and for our staff. So we're very pleased with this
process. Okay. And I've got some other questions about the
primarily around the planning and development special revenue fund.
You mentioned that some of the general fund employees support
the efforts of that and vice versa.
Some of the employees that are paid for through the Planning and
Development Special Revenue Fund also do general fund functions and
vice versa. Okay. I guess my question is,
was that the intent of putting the I mean, was it was
it all was it supposed to be the Planning and Development Special Revenue Fund over
at permitting was supposed to just support those efforts, or was it
always meant to be fluid? Well,
so when the fund was created so
the fees are for land development activities that the
City of Houston does, whether it's Platting or permitting over at
the permitting center. So the fund
supports those activities, but it also supports
some development related activities, such as a few positions
that do minimum lot size designations, because those are development related.
It supports some of our transportation planning. And as
we have worked with this fund for three years, what we've
been able to determine is that some team members specialties
really afford them. They have the best skills and the best ability to
do a type of service such as outreach. Some of
that outreach will be development related, some of it won't
be. And so that's why we charge back and
reimburse the funds, is because if, say, for instance, one of our
planners is terrific at outreach,
she will work with the development side work as well
as the non development side. And we need to make sure we're clear on
which fund pays her. Okay, I have some more if you put me back in.
Did I answer your question? Yes. Okay, let's be mindful. We're about
45 minutes behind schedule.
Council Member Cayman,
I'm happy to defer to Council Member Alcorn if she wants to wrap up.
All right, Director, first off,
I know you all are dealing with a lot right now. And then on top
of that, to throw in redistricting. I don't
know how you all are doing it all, but thank you. And again.
David Fields. So many others. I'm not
going to start naming people because I'll get in trouble. But whether it's in District
C, the Historic districts, the Heritage District,
Vision Zero's Implementation, I'm so excited to hear about the
new freight mapping. I think that's going to be a very big deal,
especially in District C.
On top of all of that, any meeting my constituents have asked for,
you and your staff have been to. So thank you for being
available to our residents for all of their questions. In times
of great concern and need. One of the concerns I just
want to continue to raise and elevate in any way
that I can. I know as a city we have to build denser,
we have to have affordable housing, we have to make it convenient for
people in parts of the district. I continue to be concerned
about, for example, in Shady Acres, in Lazy Brook Timbergrove,
but especially Shady Acres that as we're building hyper
densely, we still don't have the infrastructure to mitigate
and manage all of the building that's going on. So I know that's
not a question. I just, on behalf of residents, have to continue to
emphasize the need to as we build dense
that we're building responsibly. And I know you take that charge very
seriously as it relates to the department itself.
May I respond to that for a moment? We do take it very seriously
and I think that our Livable Places Action Committee is working very hard
and very intently on fixing some of that. But I also want to say
that our partnership with the Houston Public Works Department is better
than it has ever been. And so the work that we're doing with development
and developers and property owners in the city is
really being amplified by the work that they're doing in the
general I'm sorry, in the Chief
Engineer's office. And the partnership is really putting forth
ideas for a better Houston and I couldn't
agree more. So, again, I appreciate that and really look forward to the
additional measures and improvements as they come along really quickly.
Future needs of the department. Again, tight budget,
what do we need to be on the lookout for or be aware of that's
not being satisfied by this current budget this year. So we
anticipate future needs of the department include, besides special revenue
fund activities, some general fund activities that could be that
conservation District working with the Conservation District is
a new program we're creating this year. We also would like to do
more resiliency plans for neighborhoods that would take more team members.
And we believe that the tools we have in place,
such as minimum lot size and minimum building line, are very good
for neighborhoods and they very much want to opt into them. Having the number
of people who can support that has been difficult recently.
Council Member Alcorn, as you mentioned, Director, you have
really increased the number of plans you're reviewing over at the permitting center.
So I noticed in your budget, it looks like going to get two more FTEs
in development design review, one more in
development services, three more in development support services.
Do you think that that's sufficient to I noticed in today's
dashboard you've got about 1900 plans in
planning at about 27 days. I know you're working towards a goal of
13 days for commercial, ten days for residential. So do you think
you need more people there to tackle the great number of
increase in plans. I think that right now we are seeing
such an immense increase in the plans that, yes,
right now I could use double the team,
but I have to be really cautious because the Special Revenue Fund is
a self fulfilling fund. It is not like right.
Not like the general fund. It comes from the fees
that we collect and we have this
huge expense for Plat tracker. And so as that works its way
out to you for approval over the next month, once I
get that number nailed down, I'll be able to analyze where I can
go and how I can increase funding at a much more safe
way. So that's when I'll take that step. Does your department offer customer
paid expediting? Yes, we do expedite. Can you describe that
to me a little bit? So if
a customer asks for expedited review and pays it
by 09:00 a.m. That morning, I believe
we have the plan out for them within 24 hours
of the 24 hours from the time they pay the fee, I believe.
Does the charge depend on the complexity of the project or is
it a flat? Council Member, can I get back to you? Sure, absolutely. Thank you
very much. Thank you,
Director and Mr. Hamilton for your presentation. You all are now dismissed.
Thank you. We will now begin the public comment period.
We will start with our virtual speakers. Please press star six
to unmute when you hear your name. The first speaker is Saba Blandy.
Hey, good afternoon. I just had two quick questions for this
department. I appreciate the expansion to the High Comfort
Bicycle Network, and I was curious what the overall timeline of expansion
was. And I was also curious, as somebody who lives near
a bus stop, if there's a plan to make sidewalks near public transit
Ada accessible, because the ones near ours are not.
So we'll need to get back to
you on question one. So if you want to send that to District E
at houstontx Gov, we'll get you a specific response on that.
As it pertains to question two?
As it pertains to question two, yes, I believe there is a
strategy in place to provide sidewalks and Ada accessibility
for Metro bus stops in those areas.
And there are some plans that are in the works that our
offices are collaborating with Metro. I know in District
J we did a recent initiative with Metro
regarding our bus stops, and they were very intentional on
finding bus stops with proper sidewalks and
Ada accessibility. So that is on
our radar. That is a priority for us to continue to look at and
be able to be mindful to try to get as many bus stops
up to date with those type of amenities as possible around the
city. So if you see one in your area, wherever you are
in your district, try to advocate for that. Reach out to your district.
Council Member and stay engaged with us.
Absolutely. Thank you. Council Member David Robinson. Thank you,
Chair, and Ms. Blanding, thank you again for being here so alertly
with our panels. And in this case, I think
I'd like to call your attention to the city's website for the
TTI committee briefings. Recently, there has been a
presentation, yes, by planning, but also in conjunction
with the Mayor's Office for persons with disabilities. Director Gabe Costarez
has addressed some of those things. And I think that the
video recording of that you would find interesting and perhaps
helpful. And if you need a reference to where within the
presentation that content occurred, my office can help you.
If you reach out to the AtLarge two office for that.
So I appreciate the good questions and your ongoing attendance.
Thank you so much.
Amanda psy.
Please press star six to unmute.
Amanda Sigh, please press star six to unmute.
Hello.
I'm not prepared right now, so I'll go ahead and yield my time.
Mr. Jason oliver.
Hello, and thank you to the Planning Department
for the Redistricting website is really valuable.
It has a lot of resources. It's been helpful for me trying
to understand this and the language accessibility there.
I'm wondering if there's a centralized online place where the CIP
kind of information is being shared during these meetings are all accessible.
That's a whole separate budget adoption.
That's much hard to navigate. And I feel like it's kind of falling
under the radar with all that's happening with Redistricting.
And then second, as the city transitions to outcomes based budgeting,
the Finance Department told us that planning would be the group
to facilitate public engagement around it. So what existing
plans are in action and how can we enhance the budget process to
encourage engagement? For example, holding workshops before the
proposed budget is released and extending the timeline so that there's more opportunity
and it's not kind of rushed in the way that it is now.
Council Member David Robinson. Yes. Mr. Oliver,
thanks again for your good question. I think with regard to the
activities of the CIP programs,
we have the last meeting tonight. As I'm sure you're aware, the District
B office and our District B meeting
is this evening. But I think your question is a good one to get all
of those activities consolidated in a place on the
web. So I'm interested in following up with you. Of course,
that relates to activities, as you said, central to the
Finance Department as well as to public works.
So to have some kind of centralized location for that
CIP information, let's see what we can do to help you on
that one. Okay. And additionally jason.
Thank you. We are working to schedule our CIP
special call BFA meeting in June. So after we
go through the budget presentations as a committee, we will
take up the CIP and present that to the public so
you can stay engaged with the process through that way as well.
So we'll put the information out on that shortly.
Thank you. That completes our public
speakers.